hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to explain
and give you the five steps in how you
can become a millionaire
as a result of the 2020 crash that we're
in right now
now most people right now are feeling
extremely worried and i said oh my
goodness we just need to survive
this crash that's what people are saying
we just need to get through
and i so strongly disagree with that
because when i started out and when i
became wealthy in properties actually
started out
in 2008-2000 time and that was
like not the same as this crash it's
very different but it was a massive
crash
and in 2008 when i was planning on how
to be a property millionaire
i bought my first house in 2009 and
everyone was saying it's a terrible time
it's a terrible time
but that was when i grew my portfolio by
age 25
i was a millionaire and now i'm a
multi-multi-millionaire and listen i
don't say that to try and
impress you but to impress upon you that
not only is it possible but also
it's very possible during downfalls and
during recessions
so i i believe i don't know what the
statistic is on this but i believe that
most millionaires
are made through recessions so you might
be
watching this video thinking no no no no
i just want to get through this you know
i'm not sure if i can be a millionaire
being a millionaire is not that much
like a million pounds isn't that much
and again i don't mean to sound like a
jerk saying this but if you think 10
okay 10 000 pounds
10 000 pounds times 10 times 10 again
that's a million pounds and it might
sound a lot right now
but it's impossible to not be a
millionaire when you have a mindset of
the millionaire
so i'm going to give you right now the
five ways that you need to think
and if you embrace this these
philosophies and this thinking
through 2020 and you get your mindset
right and apply these five teachings
it's just gonna happen it's completely
inevitable number one is
empathize as a millionaire you will not
become
successful you will not grow a big
business unless you're actually thinking
about other people dr john d martinez
says that being poor is actually
probably pretty selfish
and whilst that sounds crazy what do you
mean being poor selfish surely being
rich is greedy
actually no because when you're rich
when you become a millionaire
it's probably because you've helped a
load of people so
why do i say empathy because in order to
make money you've got to first put
yourself in the shoes of other people
right now people need different things
to what they needed in 2019
people's needs have changed and what i
see so many people doing right now is
they're saying
i want people to buy my products people
to buy my deals trying to push
their business trying to push their
agenda on everybody else
rather than thinking actually what do
people want
what what do people need right now
and how can i give it to them that's the
first step i've got to think what are my
customers need what
are what do people need right now and
you can only think like that when you
truly
empathize and put yourself in other
people's shoes that's how you need to
think
not how can i get through this crash
if you think like that then yeah you may
survive or may not survive
but if you think how can i help other
people in this crash
what are people's problems right now and
how can i solve them that's the first
step the second step is
you need to adapt massively adapt
you will not make it in this time unless
you adapt
the businesses that are adapting are
doing
very very well even some of the tiny
small businesses some of the struggling
businesses last year
are now thriving where i live
in my village there was there's a little
restaurant and it's always really quiet
but there's hardly anyone in there now i
don't know the finances of the
restaurant but i imagine
they'll probably not making too much
money they're probably struggling i'd
drive past i'd see that well i used to
sometimes go in to try and support the
business
then all restaurants closed down okay so
now i'm thinking
that business is probably going to go
bust you know there's so many
restaurants that are going bust right
now
this restaurant right now is thriving
like they've been they've adapted
they've empathized what the people want
and they've created like a market stall
outside of the restaurant
where they've got all the favorite
things on the menu
all day long every day there's queues
all the other restaurants are all closed
down probably gonna go burst this one
it's not just surviving this restaurant
is
thriving and the reason it's thriving is
because it's empathized
what do people need right now and it's
adapted
the restaurants that are saying we don't
do takeaways no no we don't
we don't do that we've never done that
maybe you need to adapt and do things in
2020
through this recession that you didn't
do in 2019
you've got to adapt big time you 180
adapt
second thing third thing is if you want
to make it
if you've got a business or if you're
just starting out you've got to cut all
the baggage right now
now i don't know if you're a business
person if you're just starting out as an
entrepreneur
but myself in my business i had
overheads
like big overheads our overheads as a
business were about 550 000 pounds a
month
that's over half a million pounds a
month
that my business was spending
every single month just in yeah this is
just typical this is just a spend
now we haven't we haven't fired anybody
we haven't let anybody go
and i hope we don't have to but we've
shrunk that
massively down more than 50 we've shrunk
that down
during this lockdown and we've had time
to say right you know what do we not
need to spend
who do we not need to use what do we not
need to pay for what are the
subscriptions what other and we've just
shrunk our expenses massively so again
if you want to make it through this time
and
and survive and thrive then you need to
cut all the baggage
not just talking the baggage of
overheads and finances maybe in your
situation maybe you've got
you know a couple cars take a couple
holidays living in a big house
maybe you need to cut that baggage you
need to move into an apartment
and and you need to become a millionaire
instead like when i was first a
millionaire 25
i didn't have loads of fancy fancy stuff
so cut the baggage but also cut the
baggage
cut the negativity out your life cut the
friends that aren't supporting you
cut the tv shows just cut the baggage
you got to do that
right now leave behind in in
the beginning of 2020 anything that's
going to hold you back or get in your
way
of becoming a millionaire cut it chop it
and don't be afraid to do that
next number four massive massive is you
need to be an
opportunity finder right now not a
problem finder
are there problems right now in 2020 yes
they are the world not just the country
the world is flooded with problems
everybody is upset everybody's scared no
one can leave the house
problems now you can either join
most people join average people and say
yeah there aren't
loads of problems i can't go out either
or
you can join the other group of people
who are the rich people
and instead of finding problems you can
find opportunities
opportunities to solve those problems
maybe
how can you solve people's problems
right now what are the opportunities
there was a guy who i just spoke to one
of my students and
he is finding people right now who've
got rent to rent deals
that one out there i don't want this
anymore they've got a problem
then he's finding people that are
looking for rent to rent deals right now
and i want something he is bringing the
two
together and charging a fee so that's it
find people's problems
and solve them don't you find problems
right now there's enough problems going
on right now
for someone else to be finding more
problems find opportunities
find motivated sellers that are
desperate to sell their property they
have to sell it this year
because they have maybe a contract or
something or a joint venture agreement
where they have to sell it
and now they're like oh man and they've
got a problem and then you come in
negotiate the price down and find a
buyer bring the two together maybe
you can do this starting with no money
and the number five is what number five
is this
you gotta be courageous outrageously
courageous taking massive action
not procrastinating actually stepping
out and taking massive action and having
courage
that's what that's number five while
everybody else is scared
being lazy getting sloppy thinking about
excuses
worrying anxious you can't do that you
just got to take
massive action and be absolutely
courageous be fearless
don't care what anybody thinks don't
care what anybody's saying
do what you need to do step out and do
it those are the five things
if you do those five things and that's
your mindset it's like yeah well i just
empathize with people
and then i adapt and i cut all baggage
and i find
opportunities not problems and i take
massive action and i'm courageous if you
do that
that's called a millionaire mindset if
you have a millionaire mindset
it's inevitable that you will become a
millionaire and it can happen as a
result of this crash
it can happen don't let your economy be
the same as the economy create your own
economy
become a millionaire that's my message